Esta vez hablaremos un poco sobre sólidos
moleculares. Así que como un pequeño repaso
recordemos que ya hemos hablado de sólidos
iónicos, donde los iones forman este tipo de
retículas. Estos son los iones positivos
y después tenemos los iones negativos,
los cuales atraen a los positivos y los positivos
a los negativos. Estamos mostrando una versión
bidimensional, pero no olvides que en realidad
se forma una retícula tridimensional; esto es
un sólido iónico. Bien, además hemos visto los
sólidos metálicos, en donde tenemos metales que
contribuyen con algunos electrones de valencia a
un mar de electrones; básicamente, lo que tenemos
son cationes positivos que están en este mar de
electrones. También vimos sus propiedades, como
una buena conductividad eléctrica, maleabilidad,
etcétera. Ahora hablaremos sobre lo que pasa
cuando tenemos no metales. Podemos encontrar a
los no metales en color amarillo justo aquí, y
también se incluye el hidrógeno, los gases nobles
también son no metales, pero no son reactivos,
así que hablaremos de los no metales reactivos.
Ellos pueden formar moléculas entre sí. Por
ejemplo, un yodo puede unirse a otro yodo con un
enlace covalente, así tendremos la molécula I₂.
Tenemos cosas como dióxido de carbono, donde cada
carbono puede unirse a 2 oxígenos. Estas moléculas
se forman mediante enlaces covalentes entre no
metales. Ahora bien, cuando hablamos de sólidos
moleculares, hablamos de poner un montón de estas
moléculas juntas, es decir, supongamos que ponemos
muchas moléculas de yodo juntas, entonces las
fuerzas intermoleculares a una temperatura lo
suficientemente baja son suficientes para mantener
estas moléculas como un sólido. ¿A qué me refiero
con todo esto? Veamos unos ejemplos. Esta de
aquí es la imagen del yodo sólido y se compone
de estas moléculas de yodo. Ahora bien, cada una
de estas moléculas de yodo se forma por un enlace
covalente entre 2 átomos de yodo, pero esto es
un sólido porque existen suficientes fuerzas de
dispersión. Hablamos de las fuerzas de dispersión
de London que se forman por dipolos temporales,
que inducen dipolos en moléculas vecinas. Por
ejemplo, por casualidad, sólo por un momento es
posible que haya más electrones en este extremo
de la molécula de yodo, lo que crea una carga
parcial negativa; eso significa que algunos de
los electrones en este extremo de la molécula
vecina de yodo pueden ser repelidos por la carga
negativa, lo que crea una carga parcial positiva,
por lo que tenemos un dipolo temporal que induce
un dipolo en la molécula vecina y eso hará que se
atraigan entre sí. A esto le llamamos fuerzas
de dispersión de London, y a una temperatura
lo suficientemente baja puede mantener todas
las moléculas juntas como un sólido. Ahora,
es importante mencionar que hago énfasis en la
temperatura suficientemente baja, ya que estos
sólidos moleculares no se mantienen unidos por
los enlaces covalentes. Los enlaces covalentes
mantienen unidas cada una de las moléculas, pero
todas las moléculas se mantienen juntas sólo por
estas fuerzas de dispersión bastante pequeñas,
tienden a tener puntos de fusión relativamente
bajos. Por ejemplo, el yodo sólido que
tenemos aquí tiene un punto de fusión de
113.7°C. Y estoy seguro que estás pensando
que este no es un punto de fusión tan bajo,
es mayor que la temperatura a la que hierve
el agua, y sería bastante incómodo para
cualquiera de nosotros experimentar 113.7°C.
Sin embargo, esta temperatura es relativamente
baja cuando hablamos de sólidos. Pensemos en
la temperatura que se requiere para fundir,
digamos, sal de mesa. Ya hemos hablado de eso,
o la temperatura que se requiere para fundir
hierro. Hablamos de cientos de grados y en algunos
sólidos son miles de grados Celsius. Así que este
es un punto de fusión mucho menor. Entonces,
por principio general, los sólidos moleculares
tienden a tener puntos de fusión relativamente
bajos. Ahora, ¿qué tan buenos serán conduciendo
electricidad? Pausa el video y piénsalo.
Bueno, para ser conductores de electricidad,
de alguna forma la carga necesita moverse a través
del sólido. A diferencia de los sólidos metálicos,
no tenemos aquí un mar de electrones donde se
pueda mover, por lo tanto, estos tienden a ser
malos conductores de electricidad. Podemos ver
otro ejemplo de sólido molecular por acá. Esto es
dióxido de carbono sólido, también conocido como
hielo seco. Lo que vemos por aquí es que en cada
una de estas moléculas tenemos 1 carbono unido
a 2 oxígenos, tiene un enlace doble con cada uno
de estos oxígenos, éstos son enlaces covalentes
que forman cada una de estas moléculas. Pero lo
que mantiene juntas a todas las moléculas son
las fuerzas de dispersión, y las fuerzas entre
las moléculas son tan débiles que el dióxido de
carbono realmente no se funde, no cambia a estado
líquido. Si aumentas la temperatura lo suficiente
como para superar estas fuerzas intermoleculares,
estas fuerzas de dispersión, entonces se
sublimará, lo que significa que pasará
directamente de estado sólido a estado gaseoso, y
lo hace a una temperatura muy baja, se sublima a
-78.5°C. Si alguna vez manejas hielo seco, lo
cual no te recomiendo que hagas sin guantes,
porque si lo tocas dañará tu piel. De hecho lo
hice recientemente en la fiesta de cumpleaños
de mi hijo: estábamos jugando con hielo seco,
pero no juegues con eso porque es increíblemente
frío. A esa temperatura, de un estado sólido no
se fundirá a un estado líquido, sino que pasará
directamente a estado gaseoso. Ahora bien,
lo último que quiero que pensemos es por qué
diferentes sólidos moleculares tienen diferentes
puntos de fusión. Comparemos, por ejemplo,
el yodo molecular con el cloro molecular. Cada uno
de ellos formarán sólidos moleculares. Ya vimos
hace unos minutos el caso del yodo, ¿cierto? ¿Cuál
de éstos formará sólidos moleculares con un punto
de fusión mayor? Pausa el video y piénsalo. Como
hemos dicho, cada una de estas moléculas se forma
con enlaces covalentes entre 2 átomos, y lo que
mantiene juntas estas moléculas son las fuerzas de
dispersión. En videos pasados, cuando hablamos de
las fuerzas de dispersión, hablamos de los dipolos
temporales y los dipolos inducidos, y cómo es más
probable que se formen entre átomos y moléculas
más pesados, porque tienen nubes de electrones
mayores y son más polarizables. Si comparamos el
yodo con el cloro podemos ver que el yodo es un
átomo más grande y por ello es más polarizable,
lo que significa que, en general, tiene fuerzas
de dispersión más fuertes. Sólo como recordatorio:
las fuerzas de dispersión funcionan entre
moléculas. Cada molécula tiene un enlace covalente
entre 2 átomos de yodo, mientras que las fuerzas
de dispersión se encuentran entre las moléculas y,
dado que tienen fuerzas de dispersión más fuertes,
podríamos esperar que el sólido molecular que
forma el yodo tenga un punto de fusión mayor que
el sólido molecular que forma el cloro. De hecho,
vamos a escribir los valores por aquí. El punto
de fusión del sólido molecular formado por el
yodo es de 113.7°C, ya lo habíamos mencionado,
mientras que el sólido molecular que forma el
cloro tiene un punto de fusión de -101.5°C, lo
que es muy frío. Así que el yodo tiene un punto
de fusión mayor porque sus fuerzas de dispersión
son más fuertes. Sin embargo, como mencionamos,
estas fuerzas de dispersión todavía no son tan
fuertes, esta no es una temperatura tan alta
a comparación de los puntos de fusión de otros
tipos de sólidos que ya hemos visto en el pasado.